Freiheit für Dr Bianca Witschel Trommeln
und Fahnen vor der Justizvollzugsanstalt
Chemnitz hunderte Menschen protestieren
gegen die Inhaftierung der Ärztin sie
soll in der corona-pandemie unter
anderem hunderte falsche
maskenbefreiungen ausgestellt haben in
der querdenkerszene ist sie dafür eine
freiheitsheldin
angemeldet hat die Protestkundgebung die
Gruppe freies Sachsen ihre Ideologie
rechtsextrem die Parolen vor der JVA
schroff staatsfeindlich und solange
dieser Staat die Leute die in schweren
Zeiten für Freiheit und Rechte und
Menschlichkeit eingestanden haben
gnadenlos verfolgt so lange werden wir
ihn gnadenlos angreifen denn solange
beweist er uns dass er nicht legitim ist
aber liebe Freunde das was man hier in
Sachsen was man in der Bundesrepublik in
den letzten drei Jahren mit uns gemacht
hat das ist nichts anderes als das was
kriminelle Regime in AUT oritären
Staaten veranstalten mit ihrem Region
heute ist diese Politik nur noch eine
korrupte kriminelle Bande die dingfest
gemacht werden muss
die freien Sachsen gehören heute zu den
aktivsten Gruppen am rechten Rand
organisieren fast im Wochenrhythmus
Propaganda Veranstaltungen aus diesem
Grund wird die rund 1000 Mitglieder
zählende Gruppierung vom
Verfassungsschutz beobachtet und
analysiert hier stuft man sie als
verfassungsfeindlich ein
die freien Sachsen fordern den Austritt
des Freistaates aus der Bundesrepublik
aus der EU aus der NATO und letztlich
eine Forderung die wir auch für
extremistisch halten weil nicht mit der
Verfassung vereinbar dass Menschen aus
Westdeutschland die hier als Beamte oder
als Richter tätig sind dass da die
Forderung besteht diese sozusagen in
einem geregelten Verfahren wieder in
ihre Heimatländer abzuschieben
die Parolen der freien Sachsen sind
schlicht aber wirkungsvoll im
sächsischen Erzgebirgskreis eröffnet die
Organisation im Mai 2023 einen ersten
Bürger treffen mitten in Aue schlimmer
erstmals erlauben die freien Sachsen
hier Dreharbeiten Anwesen sind
rechtsradikale Putins aber auch Bürger
aus der Mitte der Gesellschaft mit
Appetit auf deutsche Küche
diskutiert wird über Politik und
Gesellschaft selbstverständlich aus
rechter Sicht es ist eine Gegenkultur
die hier in Sachsen immer mehr in die
Gesellschaft eindringt
angesprochen fühlen sich im Grunde
genommen alle diejenigen
die mit den politischen Zuständen in
Deutschland nicht zufrieden sind die
frustrierte die enttäuschten diejenigen
die sich nach und nach von dieser
Gesellschaft von diesem Staat nicht mehr
repräsentiert fühlen und die sich
sozusagen vor dieser Gesellschaft
abwenden die freien Sachsen haben es
geschafft und das ist auch ihr Ziel in
die Mitte der Gesellschaft mit ihren
plumpen einfachen Parolen vorzudringen
und insoweit kann man auch sagen dass
sie die Krisen Gewinner sind
[Applaus]
Protest der freien Sachsen in Mittweida
im Mai 2023
in der mittelsächsischen Kleinstadt ist
eine Containeranlage für Asylsuchende
geplant für die freien Sachsen ein
dankbarer Ort für Propaganda hier
erreichte die am rechten Rand
konkurrierende AFD bei den letzten
Landtagswahlen fast 30 Prozent jetzt
befeuern die freien Sachsen die
Ängste vieler Menschen
[Musik]
überall da wo sie Millionen Fremde in
unser Land holen wollen kann es nur eine
richtige Antwort geben raus auf die
Straße es ist Zeit für Protest
Hauptredner Michael Brück ist ein
politstratege mit Vergangenheit bei der
Neonazi Organisation die rechte sein
Gesprächspartner ist Stefan Trautmann er
kommt aus der npd-jugend heute ist auch
eher Funktionär der freien Sachsen
wir wollen klare Fakten schaffen für
Corona Asylproblematik die ganze
Änderung der Allgemeinheit ist
Bewusstsein wieder Sachsen stolz sein
darf dass man auch als deutsch
sein darf aber eben auch als Sachsen
in Mittweida zeigt sich das auch
Menschen ohne organisatorischen
Hintergrund zu den Kundgebungen finden
an der Leipziger Universität erforscht
der Soziologe Johannes Kies die
Aktivitäten der freien Sachsen er
beobachtet den Maß der Gruppe von den
Rändern in die Mitte also die freien
Sachsen haben es geschafft aus dieser
subkulturellen neonazistischen
Bewegungen heraus zu treten und auch
stärkeren Rückgriff auf auf neue Rechte
Strategien der Popularisierung der
selbstverharmlosung eine größere Breite
der Bevölkerung auch zu erreichen und
dabei da muss man dann sozusagen neben
dem Angebot auch die Nachfrage angucken
dabei eben die vorhandenen Ressentiments
in der Gesellschaft besser ansprechen zu
können als das eben NPD oder dritter Weg
vorher konnten
doch welche Strategie haben die freien
Sachsen was ist ihr Programm in Chemnitz
hat der Vorsitzende Rechtsanwalt Martin
Kohlmann seine Kanzlei der Jurist stand
bereits selbst wegen Volksverhetzung vor
Gericht heute wird er mit der Vision
eines entschlackten Staates
eine Demokratie neigt dazu also sich
immer mehr zu krallen und wenn ein Staat
sich letztlich so viele Bereiche
untertan gemacht hat
dass es wenig für eigene Entscheidungen
mehr übrig lässt dann ist das eben
leider diktatorisches System und dann
diktatorisches System wie wir gerade
erleben kann auch demokratisch sein wir
brauchen einfach mal wieder 90%
Kompetenzen dem Staat wieder weggenommen
und dann regelt sich vieles von selber
symbolträchtige Aktionen sollen den
Widerstand gegen das etablierte System
unterstützen ein Beispiel die sogenannte
Aktion Fahnen Tausch Menschen die ihre
deutsche Fahne einsenden erhalten von
den Freien Sachsen eine königlich
sächsische Fahne retour Aktionen auch
eines ganzheitlichen Widerstands denn
auch den grundsatzgleicher Wahlen möchte
Kohlmann auf den Kopf stellen
also Mitbestimmung der Leute ist schon
ganz wichtig was ich nicht einsehe ist
dieses one man one vote Prinzip also das
jeder die gleiche Stimme hat also es
kann nicht logisch und richtig sein dass
19-jähriger dessen Lebensleistungen bis
jetzt darin besteht weil Ausbildungen
abgebrochen zu haben das gleiche den
gleichen Einfluss auf die Gestaltung
unseres Landes hat wie ein
50-jähriger Familienvater mit eigenem
Unternehmen und 15 Angestellten der noch
ehrenamtlich in der Feuerwehr tätig ist
und noch einen Verein leitet
die freien Sachsen erringen inzwischen
Wahlerfolge selbst in Konkurrenz zur
ebenfalls rechtsextremen AFD und das mit
dem Ziel einen vor demokratischen Staat
zu errichten da muss man unterscheiden
zwischen den Aktivist an der Spitze die
da sicherlich im Einzelnen konkretere
Vorstellungen haben also einen
Ständestaat einzurichten in dem eine
Elite regiert Herr Reklamation so wie es
der Führerstand im Nationalsozialismus
ja auch gemacht hat
mit Versatzstücken von monarchistischen
Systemen auch ich glaube was die
Gefolgschaft das Milieu dass die freien
Sachsen auch erfolgreich ansprechen
angeht ist es viel viel diffuser da ist
die Ablehnung des demokratischen Systems
noch der kleinste gemeinsame Nenner
letztendlich
bei repräsentativen Umfragen der
Leipziger Universität haben vor
demokratische Positionen längst viele
Befürworter in der Autoritarismus Studie
aus dem Jahr 2022 wünschen sich knapp 15
Prozent der Befragten eine starke Partei
die Deutschlands Volksgemeinschaft
verkörpere und fast 24 Prozent wünschen
sich diese starke Partei zumindest
teilweise wir messen nicht nur in
Sachsen aber durchaus in bestimmten
ostdeutschen Bundesländern noch mal
verstärkt ein durchaus beachtliches
Potenzial an autoritären
antidemokratischen ein äh Einstellung
also dem Wunsch nach einer starken
Person nach einer einzigen starken
Partei also eben nicht dieses kleinen
kleinen was man in der Politik dann eben
beobachtet also es gibt
Aushandlungsprozesse zwischen
verschiedenen Parteien das sind
Komplexitäten die viele Menschen nicht
aushalten können
für die freien Sachsen sind das die
Einfallstore kompliziert empfundenen
demokratischen Strukturen setzen sie
schlichte autoritäre Antworten entgegen
auch eine neue Monarchie wird ins Spiel
gebracht
unseren König der wird als kleinster
Prinz
schon unterrichtet dem werden die Dinge
beigebracht die man eben können muss
wenn man einen Gemeinwesen
repräsentieren und und leiten will und
das konnte dann auch und gerade in
Sachsen haben wir in 1000 Jahren doch
nur sehr wenig schwache Nummern gehabt
ein zwei freier vielleicht muss man
sagen muss na ja also dass das war schon
ein bisschen in eine dünne Besetzung
aber was haben wir denn in 100 Jahren
Demokratie gehabt da haben wir doch bis
jetzt nur Fehlbesetzungen gehabt und das
ist auch eines der Kernmerkmale der
freien Sachsen indem sie unsere
Gesellschaft und die Vertreter unsere
Staates eben in einer Art und Weise
lächerlich machen und verächtlich machen
dass das Misstrauen der Bevölkerung
gegen den Start und seine Institutionen
immer größer wird und was wir heute hier
erleben ist eben eine große
misstrauensgemeinschaft das sind alles
die Menschen die sich eben nicht mehr
repräsentiert fühlen Menschen die auf
Antworten warten die sie nicht bekommen
und die deswegen das Heil irgendwo
suchen eben bei solchen extremistischen
Bewegungen wie den freien Sachsen die
freien Sachsen haben mobilisiert diesmal
nach Dresden anders ist ein Gedenkmarsch
zum 17 Juni 1953 der Tag an dem sich
Menschen in der DDR gegen den
Stalinismus erhoben 70 Jahre später sind
es auch Rechtsextremisten die den Tag
nutzen um für sich zu werben und noch
etwas fällt auf der Stand der freien
Sachsen ist auch ein Treffpunkt für
Aktivisten anderer rechtsextremer
Gruppen hier in Dresden sind die rechten
Teil eines großen Bündnisses
und so sind simpelkinder was ist das
denn grünen Krach tausende Menschen sind
an diesem 17 Juni nach Dresden gekommen
Querdenker rechtsradikale Anhänger der
freien linken und Friedensaktivisten sie
alle demonstrieren gemeinsam gegen die
Regierung es geht um Frieden und
Freiheit so ein Motto die Veranstaltung
offenbart aber auch die Konturen einer
neuen Widerstandsbewegung gegen das
politische System Deutschlands keine
Berührungsängste kaum Tabus und überall
die königlich sächsische Fahne das
Symbol der freien Sachsen
ja mich sorgt am meisten die
Durchlässigkeit die Brüchigkeit der
bürgerlichen Mitte die Mitte der
Gesellschaft die gesellschaftlichen
Mitte ist sozusagen der Stabilitätsanker
für unsere Gesellschaftsordnung
und wenn diese sehr wenn diese Säule
sozusagen wankt oder brüchig wird dann
müssen wir zumindest aufpassen dass
dieser Erosionsprozess sich nicht
fortsetzt
Indikatoren sind einmal mehr die Befunde
der Leipziger Autoritarismus Studie über
20% der deutschen fordern ein
energisches durchsetzen deutscher
Interessen gegenüber dem Ausland über
30% Stimmen teilweise zu empirische
Mehrheiten für autoritäre Positionen es
gibt Landkreise Landstriche in denen
antidemokratische abwertende Positionen
mehr als Meinung sind also über 50% der
Leute dann doch zustimmen können ein
Beispiel wäre zum Beispiel
muslimefeindlichkeit die
flächendeckenden ganz aus Deutschland
mehrheitlich geteilt wird
ein weiterer Befund der repräsentativen
Studie über 27% befürworten die Aussage
das Ausländer nur nach Deutschland kämen
um den Sozialstaat auszunutzen mehr noch
über 30% Folgen der Aussage zumindest
teilweise rechtsextreme Positionen die
immer mehr in der Mitte ankommen wie
jetzt sichtbar wird
wir wollen keine asi Leute Heime
haben
rechtsradikale Parolen die bewusst
Ängste schüren im politischen Raum
werden sie von Gruppen wie den freien
Sachsen benutzt die Organisation bedient
sich einfacher Feindbilder Flüchtlinge
werden mit Naturkatastrophen
gleichgesetzt
wird überall wir hatten letztes Jahr
hier in Sachsen vereinzelt zumindest
Landratswahlen und Bürgermeisterwahlen
und aus dem Stand heraus haben die
freien Sachsen die nicht in jedem Ort
und jedem Landkreis angetreten sind aber
doch an einigen Orten aus dem Stand
heraus bei Landratswahlen z.B über 20%
erreicht bei einer Bürgermeisterwahl in
der Sächsischen Schweiz über 30% und an
vielen anderen Orten immerhin im Bereich
um die zehn oder fünf Prozent jedenfalls
diese politische Akzeptanz zeigt ja dass
sie in der Mitte der Gesellschaft
angekommen ist
Rechtsextremisten finden in die
Parlamente auf der Straße von mir sich
eine neue Querfront Sachsen erlebt eine
Qualität der systemfeindschaft die
offensichtlich immer weiter an Fahrt
aufnimmt